pretty gloomy forecast for the next
couple years ed it is this so this is
from the international monetary fund and
this is perhaps the most definitive take
on the state of the global economy and
obviously
much of the focus rightly now is what's
happening in ukraine what's happening in
the humanitarian crisis but there are
enormous economic consequences for
ukraine for russia
and of course for the rest of us as well
and you know we've talked a lot about
cost of living crisis here in the uk a
lot of that was brewing before this
happened but this only exacerbates it
because it pushes up prices of energy
and lots of other costs so this is
really their first take from the imf on
what this may well pretend for the rest
of us
and it's really striking it's not
especially encouraging when you look at
it the world was just recovering from
covert 19. this was supposed to be one
of the years when we're going to be
bouncing back but instead
we're going to have a big cut to
economic growth in the uk by about one
percentage point and in many other
countries as well it's worth just
looking i think we might be able to show
you a chart uh what what this actually
means for the ukraine uh and for russia
so this is ukraine and this just shows
that their annual growth forecast for
each year and it's going all the way
back to the to the 1990 early 1990s and
anything above that kind of line you
know that straight line in the middle
the zero uh is growth anything below it
is contraction and just look at what's
happened you can see the previous
forecast there relatively you know
robust growth in the next few years but
what has happened is they've just cut
that down to a 35
contraction this year in ukraine the
worst recession that you know they've
ever had since uh certainly in the
post-soviet era uh that's ukraine and
you know that's partly as a result of
obviously uh many of those refugees a
lot of people leaving the country the
enormous damage to industry to
agriculture and so on but have a look at
russia as well because i'll show you the
same chart but for russia and here it's
not as big a fall but this is the impact
here of sanctions so obviously the
previous forecast again relatively
strong uh growth talking about kind of
you know between zero and five percent
but now they are talking at the imf
about 8.5 percent contraction if you
have a look at that red line that is
actually the deepest recession since the
those kind of years in the aftermath of
the breakup of the soviet union which
was a terrible time for the russian
economy so it really just underlines
that sanctions are having a big impact
on russia or are expected to according
to the imf and the final thing that's
worth just looking at is when you look
across the world at the kind of the the
downgrades we're likely to see to many
other countries so this just those balls
are just showing you how much these
countries have been downgraded by and
what all of these charts are basically
showing you is just the rate of growth
and that matters because this is about
incomes that go into people's pockets or
not so that's less money for everyone uh
less output for everyone less activity
and in the uk it's down by a percentage
point down from 4.7 again that was going
to be our bounce back or part of our
bounce back after covert now it's only
3.7 it's pretty weak growth the next
year as well we're not quite as much
affected as germany uh or italy they
have more direct
links to to russia particularly when it
comes to energy but look you know there
are very few positive stories here it's
it's a big impact for everyone
interestingly brazil up big wheat
exporter there but that's the final
point to mention here because russia and
ukraine are such big exporters of food
and fertilizers the concern is in fact
we're already starting to see it the
food prices go up even more than was
already expected and as a result of that
what often happens you often get social
unrest particularly in emerging
economies and that's what we saw after
the last financial crisis 2008 remember
the arab spring happened after that
it's quite possible in fact the imf says
it's quite likely that we get a wave of
social unrest after this so very serious
words you know i can't remember in all
the years i've been doing this quite
such a depressing report from the imf
that has gone from seeing the world
starting to bounce back to now seeing a
massive uh a massive problem in the face
of uh
both the economy but also what's
happening uh in the military conflict
this is a short-term forecast have they
given any indications as to what's going
to happen longer term or is it just too
soon for them it's too soon and to be
honest with you all of these numbers are
are quite speculative because we just
don't know what's going to happen next
and they provided an alternative
forecast that says
well you know what happens if there are
further sanctions what happens if we
actually stop importing gas from russia
which hasn't happened you know that's
been the paradox of these sanctions
we've imposed sanctions but we're still
paying for a lot of millions of euros
hundreds of millions of euros for gas so
much of the uk but mostly mostly
mainland europe in particular germany if
that were to stop if you were to have a
genuine kind of energy sanction then
you're talking about far far worse
consequences across most of europe but
who knows that may be what it takes